yan cimon et professeur de management à
l'université laval bonsoir yan cimon
bonsoir on va parler d'abord de l'offre
en austalie de couche tard une offre de
huit milliards c'est quoi la stratégie
de coster ici ben couche tard a dit elle
même qu'elle voulait être plus présente
sur l'asie pacifique d'entrée par
l'australie un joueur comme caltex qui
possède de bons le le tiers du marché
australien de distribution d'essence à
la pompe
c'est une occasion rêvée pour eux le
faire le fait que caltex y pense c'est
aussi une bonne nouvelle parce que ils
sont dans leur identité profondément
australien il le met de l'avant et donc
c'était pas dans leurs plans je crois au
début de se faire acheter on avait même
du côté catex penser à des stratégies
défensives pour ne pas se faire racheter
mais maintenant que couche-tard a
bonifié son offre le conseil
d'administration vous l'avez dit a un
peu changé d'idée c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les actionnaires ça peut
aussi pour stratégiquement pour couche
tard est une belle porte d'entrée sur la
zone asie pacifique puisque la marque a
text est très bien connu dans la zone
d'influencé australienne donc on pense
par exemple à singapour hong kong taiwan
et autres
donc c'est plutôt intéressant dans le
portefeuille d'activités de couche tard
donc c'est plus que l'australie c'est
plus que caltex c'est l'asie pacifique
qui visé ici oui dans ce cas ci c'est
une tête de pont très intéressante sur
le marché australien qui lui est un
marché qui est somme toute assez
semblable dans ses caractéristiques au
marché nord américain c'est à dire que
les consommateurs australiens ressemble
un peu malgré quelques différences
culturelles ressemble un peu dans nos
habitudes de consommation au nord
américain ça c'est le côté facile de
l'histoire mais bien évidemment ce qu'on
va chercher avec cette acquisition la
c'est aussi cette masse de marché là qui
permettra éventuellement de redéployer
les activités de couche-tard ailleurs
faut dire qu'un texte une acquisition
qui pourrait être structurantes aussi
parce que des grands joueurs de cette
qualité là même si le marché très
fragmenté les occasions d'achat sont
somme toute assez limité donc ça serait
un très très beau coup pour couche tard
est ce que ça tombe à point nommé pour
couche tard et pour qu'un texte aussi
compte tenu que les marges de caltech
sont quand même sous pression et que
l'économie de l'australie ralenti
oui tout à fait et puis on se rappelle
que beaucoup d'investisseurs de caltex
était insatisfait de la performance de
la direction de cartes ex voulait plus
de rendement d'ailleurs ça mettait
beaucoup de pression sur le président
dans ce cas ci peut-être que c'est une
raison qui explique le fait que le
conseil d'administration choisissent
finalement de se pencher sérieusement
sur l'offre de couche-tard
mais il reste que le domaine si on veut
du dépanneur le fameux qu'une vigne en
australie est un domaine qui est très
très concurrentiel caltex avait des
alliances avec des joueurs comme word
par exemple qui est un grand officier
australiens mais d'autres aussi mais il
faut dire que l'australie c'est quand
même un marché dans le segment du
dépanneur ou seven eleven par exemple
est très présent il savait nous les
veines est très présent aussi dans le
reste de l'asie donc ce sera ils ont un
point de contact très fort entre couches
par les cv nous n'avons propriété
japonais ce maintenant même savin seven
eleven
les acquisitions sont quand même très
importante dans l'histoire de
couche-tard et d'aller bouchard le le
fondateur est ce que cette stratégie par
acquisitions est toujours la meilleure
pour couche tard si couche-tard veut
continuer de grandir à ce rythme là et
surtout grandir vite elle n'aura pas le
choix que de procéder par acquisitions
la recette de couche tard ce qui fait
son succès et celui de l'équipe de
direction actuelle au delà de monsieur
bouchard c'est bien évidemment la
philosophie derrière les acquisitions
c'est à dire une discipline de ne jamais
payer trop cher et de se retirer si
jamais ça devient justement trop onéreux
indiscipline au niveau de la dette aussi
c'est à dire que le couche-tard wi fi
nance ces acquisitions utilise la dette
pour ce faire mais dans la discipline
d'intégration couche tard est capable de
redescendre ses niveaux de dette à des
niveaux intéressants assez rapidement
compte tenu de l'ampleur des
transactions qu'elle fait ce qui lui
donne les coudées franches donc si elle
réussit à garder cette discipline qui a
caractérisé cette acquisition passé si
elle réussit aussi à intégrer ces
entreprises là qu'ils sont on l'espère
un cas de cartes ex de cultura c'est
compatible à la culture que je t'assure
coquet et bien là on ne peut qu espérer
le meilleur
oui il reste que comme on dit en bon
français le diable est dans les détails
et donc le marché australien n'est pas
un copier coller du marché américain où
le marché canadien mais comme couche
tard a montré qu'elle avait une bonne
capacité d'internaliser des entreprises
étrangères avec l'acquisition de statoil
notamment et bien là de se dire des
réseaux distribution de statoil pas de
statoil allemagne mais elle donc elle a
montré qu'elle est capable de faire ce
poids là sur la scène internationale ce
qui augmente sa crédibilité aux yeux des
investisseurs potentiels et des banques
d'affaires avec qui elle fait affaire
justement
seize mille magasins 133 1000 employés
chiffre d'affaires de 59 milliards de
dollars américains et couche-tard veut
doubler de taille en cinq ans est-ce que
c'est réaliste
couche-tard peut le faire si les
conditions économiques sont présentes
c'est à dire que si la croissance est au
rendez-vous si elle réussit à se
financer et surtout si les intégrations
qu'elle fait à ce moment bon et si elle
réalise ce fonds 10 on sort dans la
mesure où elle peut intégrer ces cibles
rapidement avec efficience entre odeurs
la couche tard sera capable de continuer
d'acheter surtout si l'économie est
favorable et si elle est en mesure de
bien contrôler à la fois sa trésorerie
mais aussi sa dette et le cannabis dans
le cas du cannabis c'est intéressant
parce que c'est une source de revenus
potentiels pour couche tard est bon
c'est pas un secret que le cannabis à
une acceptabilité sociale intéressante
maintenant par rapport au tabac qui qui
bon lui est en perte de vitesse dans
l'esprit du public
quand on regarde maintenant les
possibilités de revenus elles sont
intéressantes le fait d'avoir un réseau
de distribution pourrait permettre un
peu de se défaire de cette dépendance au
pétrole et aux cigarettes
nourriture salée donc pas toujours bonne
pour la santé fait que ça ça pourrait
être intéressant pour générer d'autres
revenus de croissance ceci étant dit le
cannabis n'est pas nécessairement un
marché qui est facile mais dans la
mesure où couche-tard déjà un réseau de
distribution intéressant des compétences
justement de gestion de ce type de
marchandise là si on regarde les
cigarettes et l'alcool et bien là on
voit que il ya probablement là aussi des
belles possibilités et c'est la raison
pour laquelle les se positionne dans ce
domaine là merci beaucoup et yan cimon
merci elle m'a fait très plaisir d'avoir
bonne soirée au revoir